สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะครูเรียมสบายดีมคะสบายดีค่ะครูเอ๋ครู
เอ๋สบายดีไหมสบายคิดว่าสบายดีสบายดีค่ะ
สบายดีเอ่อครูเรียมคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวัน
นี้วันพฤหัสค่ะวันพฤหัสนะ
คะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ค่ะวันที่ 8
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
2022  22 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะเวลา 11 น 18
นค่ะ 1118 นนะคะอ่าใช่โอเคครูเรียมสบายดี
นะนักเรียนสบายดีมั้ยคะฟังได้มั้ยอ้อนัก
เรียนไม่รู้ไม่
ตอบไม่ตอบวันนี้วันนี้ครูเอ๋ได้ออกไปที่
ไหนมยยังค่ะยังๆเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวครูอ๋มีสอน
ตอนเช้าสอนกับครูครูเรียมแล้วก็จะต้องสอน
กับอ่ะอีกคลาสนึงเสร็จจากครูเรียมก็จะมี
อีกคลาสนึง
อืเวลาครูเอกพูดชื่อครูเรียมเป็นยังไงคะ
มันรอรอใช่มั้ยครูเรียมครูเรียมครูเรียม
พูดเร็วๆแล้วมันแป๊บทักทีอกัดลิ้นตัวเอง
เหรอคะยังยังไม่ได้กัดค่ะมันมันมันยยมัน
พันอ๋ออ๋อเพราะว่ารเรือ 2 ตัวนะฮะรเรือ 2
ตัวใช่มครูแนเรียมนะฮะเรียนมาตึ๊ดๆๆก็จะ
พันนิดนึงโอเคค่ะวันนี้ครูเรียมอยากจะคุย
เรื่องเกี่ยวกับอะไรคะอยากเล่าอะไรให้ครู
เอกกับนักเรียนฟังอืเรียมเพิ่งแบบนั่ง
เครื่อง
บินไปที่จังหวัดน้า
อตอนนี้คุตอนนี้เรียมอยู่จังหวัดน่านเหรอ
คะตอนนี้อยู่กรุงเทพฯค่ะตอนนี้อยู่
กรุงเทพอ๋อแต่ว่าเพิ่งกลับมาจากน่านค่ะ
อ๋อหมายความว่าครูเรียมเนี่ยไปน่านจ่าไป
น่านจากไหนคะจากกรุงเทพฯหรอคะใช่ค่ะจาก
กรุงเทพฯอ่ากรุงเทพฯไปน่านแล้วก็จากน่าน
กลับมา
กรุงเทพฯใช่แล้วอ๋อตอนนี้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเรียมมีเพื่อน
เพื่อนที่จังหวัดน่าน
ค่ะนั่นแหละเรียมไปอยู่น่านประมาณกี่วัน
คะคิดว่า 5 วันนะอ๋อไปไปเที่ยวหรือว่าไป
อยู่หรือว่าไปเยี่ยมเพื่อนหรือ
ว่าไปทำงานหรือ
ว่ามีอะไรอีกมีหลายอย่างมากเลยมีหลาย
อย่างก็เหมือนไปหาเพื่อนค่ะเพื่อนมีบ้าน
อยู่ที่นั่น
ค่ะใช่ิมก็เลยแบบไปหาไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวภู
เขากับเพื่อนไปหาเพื่อนแล้วก็ไปเที่ยวใช่
ๆแล้วก็ไปอยู่บ้านเพื่อนประมาณ 5 วันค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ค่ะใชใช่แล้วครูเรียมอยู่นั่น 5
วันเหรอทั้งหมดใช่อืมันเหมือนสัปดาห์ที่
แล้วครูเรียมก็ไปนั่นใช่
มั้ยใช่ออไป 5 วันแล้วก็กลับกรุงเทพฯใช่
ค่ะแล้วอยู่กรุงเทพฯอยู่กรุงเทพฯกี่วันคะ
อยู่กรุงเทพฯแค่แบบประมาณ 1 วันค่ะ 1 วัน
อ๋อ 1 วันโอเคค่ะแล้วก็จะไป
มหาสารคามมหาสารคามข้างบนมั้ยข้างล่างอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวๆๆ
ถ้าจริงๆแล้วน่าจะอยู่ตรงนี้มหาสารคามไป
ไปอีกทางนึงใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะ
มหาสารคามใช่นั่นแหละก็ไปอยู่กับเพื่อน
ค่ะ
ภูเอ๋ยมั้ยคะสนุกมากค่ะไปนอนที่บ้าน
เพื่อนแล้วที่บ้านเพื่อนเนี่ยมีมพ่อกับ
แม่เค้าด้วย
นะ
อืนั่นแหละแหคิดว่าต้องเป็นเพื่อนที่สนิท
กันนะสนิทกันมากๆถึงจะไปอยู่บ้านของ
เพื่อนได้ถึง 5 วันอือันนี้คือเพื่อนคน
นี้คือสนิทกับครูเรียมใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะอ
ใช่แล้วแบบครูเอ๋คิดยังไงถ้าเกิดเป็น
เพื่อนแต่ไม่ค่อยสนิทแล้วไปนอนบ้านครูเอ๋
5 วันแบบนั้นได้มั้ย
อ่านอนบ้านครูเอ๋หรอคะอือครูเอ๋ไม่ค่อย
ให้ใครไป
บ้านไม่ๆคือต้องสนิทอ่ะต้องสนิทมากนะสนิท
มากจริงๆอ่ะถึงจะไปที่บ้านเพราะว่าเหมือน
คือครูเอ๋ไม่ได้อยู่กับคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไงครู
เรียมอ๋อเอ๋เนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่กับพ่อแม่ตั้ง
แต่เด็กๆนะตั้งแต่เด็กๆงั้นน่ะครูเอ๋ไป
อยู่กับคุณพ่อคุณแม่ตอนครูเอ๋อายุ 7 ปีก็
เลยจะเป็นคนที่เกรงใจพ่อแม่มากแล้วก็พี่
น้องถ้าเกิดมีเพื่อนสนิทกับเอ๋แต่เอ๋ก็
ไม่ค่อยสนิทกับ
แม่คือเอ๋เอ๋อยู่กับพี่สาวแม่ใช่มพี่สาว
คุณแม่งั้นเนี่ยจะเอาไปหาไปบ้านคุณแม่
อืมไม่ค่อยดีนะคะว่าคุณแม่จะอใครทำไมไม่
สบายใจจแต่ว่าว่าก็มีนะมีที่แบบสนิทมาก
จริงๆแล้วก็ไปนอนที่บ้านที่ที่ชลบุรีได้
คะคนเดียวมั้งคนเดียวเลยมีคนเดียวใช่มั้ย
คะใช่คนเดียวเลยคนนี้ที่ได้ไปนอนเอ่อหมาย
ถึงว่าไปนอนเมื่อไหร่ก็ได้จะไปเมื่อไหร่
ก็ได้แต่ไม่ค่อยได้ไปนะหมายถึงไปนอนแล้ว
ก็รู้จักทุกคนในบ้านทุกคนเลยเลยนะฮะทุกคน
ก็ก็มีคนเดียวแต่แต่ว่าก็มีอะไรนะมีแต่
เอ๋ไปนอนบ้านเพื่อนน่ะมีหลายๆบ้านอือ่า
นึกออกมั้ยคะคือเพื่อนมานอนบ้านเอ๋เนี่ย
จะมีคนเดียวเอไม่ใช่คนเดียว 2 คนได้พี่
น้องอืแต่นอกนั้นก็จะจะไม่ค่อยได้ไปนะคะ
ส่วนบ้านที่ที่กรุงเทพฯที่กรุงเทพฯตอนครู
เออ๋เด็กๆ
อยู่กับคุณ
ป้าก็เพื่อนคนนี้เหมือนกันอ่อคนนี้เอ่อคน
เดียวนะคะที่ที่มานอนที่บ้านได้คือคุณป้า
เอ่อจะเกรงใจถ้ามานอนแล้วอาจจะบ้านเรานอน
ไม่สบายก็ไม่ได้ให้มานอนนะฮะก็มีค่ะจริงๆ
แล้วมีครูเอกไปนอนบ้านคนอื่นน่ะมีหลายๆ
บ้านแต่ว่าคนที่มานอนบ้านครูเอ๋แล้วครู
เอ๋ไปนอนบ้านเค้าคุณพ่อคุณแม่เค้ามานอน
บ้านเอ๋
เอ๋กับคุณป้าไปนอนบ้านเค้าเนี่ยก็จะมีคน
เดียว
อ๋ออืเว่าแบบเป็นเรื่องปกติเป็นเรื่อง
ธรรมดามากเลยนะที่แบบมีเพื่อนที่สนิทกัน
เนี่ยแล้วก็จะไปอยู่บ้านของเพื่อนหรือแบบ
บางทีบ้านของเรียมที่
มหาสารคามค่ะก็มีเพื่อนไปนอนน่ะไปนอนที่
บ้านอือตอนนี้เรียมสร้างสร้างบ้านมา
ประมาณ 1 ปีแล้วแหละค่ะมีเพื่อนไปนอนที่
บ้านประมาณ 3 คนะ
อืใช่นี่แหละเพื่อนสนิทถึงทำได้นะถ้าเกิด
แบบรู้จักกันนิดเดียวก็คิดว่าไม่ให้มาไม่
ๆไม่โอเค
เอ่าใช่ค่ะแล้วแล้วก็นอกจากนี้อ่ะอะไรที่
ที่ทำให้เราที่ทำให้เราดูดูออกว่าคนนี้
กับคนนี้เป็นเพื่อนสนิทกันนอกจากไปนอน
บ้านได้แล้วอ่ะอ๋อนอนบ้านเนี่ยต้องเป็น
เพื่อนสนิทมีอะไรอีกคะครูเรียมที่ว่าเอ๊ะ
ทำแล้วให้รู้ว่าคนเนี้ยเป็นเพื่อนสนิทกัน
ใช่เรียมคิดว่าเรื่องเสื้อผ้าก็ใช่นะอ้า
หรอเพื่อนสนิทเนี่ยทำไมคะไปซื้อเสื้อผ้า
ด้วยกันเหรอคะไม่ค่ะเหมือนแบบใส่เสื้อของ
เรียมได้
อ๋อใช่คือคือเพื่อนสนิทไปบ้านครูเรียมไม่
ต้องมีเสื้อผ้าไปเรียมขอเสื้อตัวนึงขอยืม
ขอยืมเสื้อหน่อยโอเคได้สำหรับเรียมโอเค
แต่ส่วนใหญ่เพื่อนเสื้ออะไรคะเสื้อตัว
ข้างนอกหรือเสื้อชั้น
ในเพื่อนเรียมอ่ะเสื้อข้างนอกอ๋อแต่เลียม
ไปหาเพื่อนน่ะมีข้างใน
ด้วยใส่ด้วยกันได้ใช่มั้ยไม่แต่ว่าเค้าเ
ซื้อแต่เขไม่ได้ใส่อ๋อเค้าซื้อไว้เค้าก็
บอกว่าอ๋อเลียมใช้ได้เลยนะอือก็เอาไปเลย
อ๋อเอาไปเลยไม่ต้องคืนใช่มั้ยคะใช่ไม่
ต้องคืนใส่แล้วก็เอาไปเลยนะอืแบบเนี้ยคือ
แบบมีเสื้อผ้าก็ให้ได้เลยค่ะอ๋อใส่ด้วย
กันได้ใช่ค่ะใส่ด้วยกันได้อันนี้คือ
เรื่องที่ 2 แล้วนะค่ะพี่เอก็นะก็กับกับ
เพื่อนน่ะเมื่อก่อนใส่ด้วยกันได้ตอนนี้
ค่ะไปเพื่อนอ่ะหลายคนค่ะบางทีอ้าเอ๊ไม่มี
นอนๆไม่ต้องกลับบ้านใส่เสื้อตัวนี้อ่ะ
เมื่อก่อนใส่ด้วยกันได้ตอนเยไปก็ใส่ด้วย
กันไม่ได้
อืขนาดขนาดใหญ่เล็กมันเปลี่ยนนะคะใช่มบาง
ทีไปบ้านเพื่อนเพื่อนก็บอกเอ๊ใส่เสื้อผ้า
เพื่อนตัวเล็กไงะเอดตัวใหญ่ก็ใส่ไม่ได้อื
หรือบางทีเพื่อนตัวใหญ่กว่าเอ๋ตัวเล็ก
กว่าก็ใส่ไม่ได้ละเอออ๋อถ้าถ้าเอ๋ตัวเล็ก
กว่าเพื่อนตัวใหญ่กว่าใส่ได้แต่ถ้าเพื่อน
ตัวเล็กและเอ๋ตัวใหญ่ก็ใส่ไม่ได้ก็ต้อง
เอาเสื้อผ้าไปเองนะคะใช่ๆค่ะอ๋อแต่ว่าถ้า
เพื่อนสนิทกันคือใส่เสื้อผ้าของเพื่อนได้
ใช่ค่ะอืแล้วก็เพื่อนสนิทกันเนี่ยจะรู้
จักพ่อกับแม่นะเราจะรู้จักถึงพ่อกับแม่
ของเพื่อน
อืหมายถึงทั้ง 2 ฝ่ายมั้ยคะใช่ค่ะทั้ง 2
ฝ่ายพ่อกับแม่ของเรียมก็เหมือนกันก็จะรู้
จักเพื่อนของเรียมค่ะแล้วก็จะเป็นเหมือน
แบบสวัสดีค่ะพ่อสวัสดีค่ะแม่เหมือนเหมือน
กับเป็นพ่อกับแม่ของตัวเองอืแล้วแล้วพ่อ
กับแม่เรียมรู้จักพ่อกับแม่เพื่อนมยคะรู้
จักค่ะ
อืใช่บางทีพ่อกับแม่ของเพื่อนเขาก็ขับรถ
ขับรถมาที่บ้านของเรียมแล้วก็เจอพ่อกับ
แม่ของเรียมอก็จะคุยกันแล้วนอนที่บ้าน
เรียมมั้ยยังนะคะพ่อกับแม่ไม่นอนแต่ว่า
นอนก็ได้นะค่ะใช่ค่ะเค้าแค่แบบขับรถผ่าน
มาแล้วก็แบบเหมือนแวะนิดนึงแล้วก็มาคุย
กันแล้วก็แบบขับรถต่อไปค่ะ
อ๋ออันนี้เพื่อนสนิทก็จะคิดถึงกันใช่มั้ย
ใช่ๆค่ะแล้วก็แบบรู้จักรู้จักพ่อกับแม่
แล้วพ่อแม่ก็จะรู้จักกัน
ค่ะใช่อืแล้วก็เรียมก็คิดว่ามีเรื่องที่
บางอย่างเรียมพูดกับคนอื่นๆไม่
ได้แต่พูดแต่พูดกับเพื่อนสนิทได้กับ
เพื่อนสนิทได้อะไรคะใช่เรื่องที่ไม่ดี
อ่ะเรื่องอะไรเดี๋ยวเรื่องไม่ดีของใคร
เรื่องที่ไม่ดีของเราเรื่องไม่ดีตัวเอง
เรื่องไม่ดีของเพื่อนสนิทเรื่องไม่ดีคน
อื่นใช่เรื่องแบบเรื่องที่แบบเรารู้สึก
อายอ่ะอาย
ไม่อยากบอกใครแต่เราก็จะเล่าให้เพื่อน
สนิทฟัง
อออย่างเช่นอะไรอยากรู้วันนี้นักเรียนทุก
คนเป็นเพื่อนสนิทครูเรียมโอไม่มีอะไรอาย
ไม่คือแบบถ้าอย่างครูเอ๋นะครูเอ๋ตอนวัย
รุ่นนะคะนักเรียนวัยรุ่นไม่ใช่ตอนนี้นะคะ
วัยรุ่นเนี่ยคือนานนานๆๆมาละอครูเอ๋เป็น
วัยรุ่น
ประมาณ 40 ปีที่
แล้วโครูเรียมเขียนให้เหน่อยได้ม 4  40
ปีที่แล้วปี 40 ปีที่แล้ว 40 ปีที่แล้วนะ
คะครูเอกเป็นวัยรุ่นเออถ้าเรื่องอายเนี่ย
ก็จะเป็นเรื่องแบบโอ๊ยบางทีดูนักร้องแล้ว
อืชอบชอบๆๆๆวัยรุ่นเนาะดูคนร้องเพลงเคย
มั้ยเคยมยดูนักร้องแล้วชอบมากรักนักร้อง
เอ่าหรือหรืออะไรนะเห็นเพื่อนผู้ชายเตะ
ฟุตบอลเก่งเคยมั้ยเคยแล้วแบบแล้วแบบอึ้ย
ชอบจังเลยอายแต่
แบบดูแล้วเฉยๆข้างในเนี่ยตุบๆๆๆเออวัย
รุ่นวัยรุ่นแต่หน้าเนี่ยเฉยๆจริงๆอดีใจ
หรือแบบใจเงียบแต่ข้างในดีใจมากๆเห็นอ่า
เห็นเพื่อนห้องอื่นหล่อๆแล้วเตะฟุตบอล
เงี้ยก็จะอ้ายใช่มอายแต่ว่าพูดกับใครไม่
ได้แต่ถ้าเพื่อนสนิแกฉันเห็นเาเตะฟุตบอล
นะหล่อมากเคยมยคะใช่เคยเรียมคิดว่าหลายๆ
คนน่ะเคยแล้วก็เล่าเล่าให้เพื่อนสนิทฟัง
ค่ะแต่อาจจะไม่ได้เล่าให้ครูเอ๋ฟังไม่ได้
เล่าให้เรียมฟังไงใชอืเออเรื่องแบบนี้
แหละที่แบบคุยกับใครไม่ได้เลยก็จะคุยกับ
เพื่อนสนิทใช่เพราะว่าคนไทยผู้หญิงไทย
เมื่อก่อนน่ะถ้าชอบก็ให้หน้าเฉยๆไม่ไม่ๆ
อ๊ไม่ใช้แบบนี้มยคู
เอออันนี้รู้อ่ะชอบอันนี้รู้ต้องแบบนี้แ
ค่ะค่ะอืในใจในใจุบๆ
ๆใจน่ะว้าวแต่ข้าง
หน้าที่
นี่ใช่ตรงข้ามกันแล้วก็จะคุยกับเพื่อนคุย
กับเพื่อนแบบเฮ้ยเธอคนนั้นแหละคนนั้นหลอ
จังเลยใช่นี่แหละแต่เราจะไม่เราจะไม่ให้
คนอื่นเห็นใช่่มั้ยคะไม่เห็นนอกจากเพื่อน
สนิทเห็นไม่เห็นว่าเราคิดอะไรใช่มใช่แล้ว
อันนี้มันดีไม่ใช่เหรอหรือไม่ดีอันนี้หรอ
ริมคิดว่าดีนะที่คุยกับเพื่อนสนิทได้ไม่
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ความรู้สึกว่าเราว้าวปิ๊ง
ผู้ชายหล่อนักร้องหล่ออย่างเงี้ยครูเอ๋ก
เสียงเล็กเสียงน้อยเลยนักเรียนอ๋อ
พะเรื่องไม่ดีใช่มั้ยเอ้ออ๋อแต่สำหรับคน
ไทยเมื่อก่อนน่ะค่ะผู้หญิงรุ่น 40 ปีที่
แล้วผู้หญิงน่ะถ้าเห็นนักร้องผู้ชายหรือ
เห็นเพื่อนที่เป็นผู้ชายแล้วหล่อๆแล้วเรา
ชอบแล้วเราอไม่ได้ให้คนอื่นเห็นว่าเราชอบ
อ่ะเมื่อก่อนนะเบอกว่าไม่ดีปี
2022 ไม่เป็นไรเนาะ 2022 ก็แบบก็โอเคนะ
ก็โอเค
นะพูดได้ให้ทุกคนรู้เอ้ยชอบได้ใช่ม 2022
แต่ 40 ปีที่แล้ว
อ่ะไม่ดีนะฮะ 40 ปีที่แล้วอืแต่ตอนเนี้ย
โอเคนะคะใช่ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋ก็เลยบอก
เอ่ออันเนี้ยเอ่อเป็นเรื่องไม่ดีเราก็จะ
บอกเพื่อนสนิทแต่ไม่บอกคนอื่นนะคะ
อืโอเคแล้วมีอะไรอีกคะครูเรียมที่เพื่อน
สนิทจะทำด้วยกันเราเรียมคิดว่ามันจะมี
อะไรที่เรา
ชอบชอบแบบคล้ายๆกันหลายๆอย่างนะอย่างเช่น
อย่างเช่นชอบกินข้าวกินข้าวร้านเดียวกัน
เราก็เลยเหมือนไปกินข้าวด้วยกันบ่อยๆอื
ใช่ครูเอ๋คิดดูว่าถ้าเกิดคนเราชอบไม่
เหมือน
กันดิมก็คิดว่ามันมันสนิทกันได้น้อยนะ
เอ่อแล้วแต่แต่ว่าส่วนใหญ่อ่ะประมาณ 60%
น่ะที่ชอบเหมเหมือนกันเออจะมีจะมีบาง
อย่างที่เหมือนกันแต่ถามว่าต้องชอบเหมือน
กันมยก็ไม่นะอืเพราะว่าเพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋
อ่ะค่ะเพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋นะอ่าชอบไม่เหมือน
กันครูครูเอ๋น่ะสมมุติว่าผู้ชายหล่อครู
เอ๋บอกคนเนี้ยหล่อเพื่อนสนิทบอกไม่หล่อคน
นี้หล่ออือันเนี้ยชอบไม่เหมือนกันหรือ
เสื้อผ้าครูเอ๋เนี่ยชอบเสื้อแบบนี้แต่
เพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋ชอบแบบ
นี้ไม่เหมือนกันครูเอ๋เนี่ยชอบดูผู้หญิง
ผมยาวครูเอ๋ชอบแต่ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบผมตัวเอง
ยาวเท่าไหร่นะคะชอบดูผู้หญิงผมยาวเพื่อน
ชอบดูผู้หญิงผมสั้นอืคือเพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋
น่ะไม่ค่อยเหมือนครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋ชอบกินอาหาร
อันนี้เพื่อนกินอันนี้แต่ว่าเราจะไปร้าน
ที่มีอาหารที่ครูเออ๋กินได้เพื่อนกินได้
อ๋อแต่เมก็ยังคิดอยู่ว่าอาจจะมีอะไรบาง
อย่างที่คล้ายๆกันก็เลยแบบอยู่ด้วยกันได้
อาจจะเป็น
เรื่องความคิดความคิดว่าความคิดของครูเอ๋
ก็คือไม่เป็นไร
อ่าเพื่อนชอบอะไรก็ได้
ความคิดของเพื่อนกับครูเอ๋ก็คือไม่เป็นไร
เอ๋ชอบอะไรก็ได้อตรงเนี้ยใชอ่าชอบอะไรก็
ได้ก็เลยคล้ายกันนะคะคล้ายกันตรงนี้ใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็เพื่อนสนิทถึงแม้ว่าเราจะมี
เรื่องที่ชอบแล้วก็ไม่ชอบไม่เหมือนกันก็
เป็นเพื่อนสนิทได้ใช่แล้วก็มีข้อดีข้อ
เสียของแต่แต่ละคนใช่ที่เราอ่ะรู้ค่ะแต่
เราก็ยังเป็นเพื่อนกัน
อือันนี้แหละเรียมคิดว่าแบบมันแบบสำคัญ
มากๆข้อดีข้อเสียเนี่ยยังไงคะอย่าๆลองยก
ตัวอย่างข้อเสียอืมข้อเสียของเรียมอ่ะ
เพื่อนของเรียมเลยเอไม่ใช่ของเรียมของ
เพื่อนของเพื่อนก็แบบเหมือนเค้าแบบเหมือน
แบบบางทีเ้าดื่มแอลกอฮอล์อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
อืใช่แล้วเราก็แบบังไม่ดื่มไม่เราก็ไม่
ชอบแต่ว่าเราก็แบบโอเคอยากทำก็ทำค่ะแล้ว
มันเป็นแล้วเราก็เลยแบบโอเคถ้าเกิดเธอ
ดื่มฉันก็จะแบบได้พาเธอกลับบ้านอ๋อมีหน้า
ที่พาเพื่อนกลับบ้านใช่ใช่ประมาณนั้นค่ะ
แต่เราก็รู้แล้วว่าเอ้ยมันไม่ดีต่อสุขภาพ
นะแต่เราก็ไม่ได้แบบไปด่าเขาว่าอย่าๆเรา
ก็แบบอืโอเคให้เค้ารู้ด้วยตัวเองถ้าเเออ
ถ้าคือจริงๆบางทีชีวิตเค้าอาจจะมีดีบ้าง
ไม่ดีบ้างใช่มั้ยคะชีวิตเราก็มีดีบ้างไม่
ดีบ้างอืเราอาจจะคิดมากเข้าใจมั้ยคิดมาก
แต่เค้าแบบสบายๆเพื่อนเอ้ยไม่เอาไม่ต้อง
คิดมากอาน่ะ
ก็ต้องเป็นเพื่อนกันได้แต่สำหรับครูเอ๋
น่ะเพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋นะคะจริงๆไม่ได้เจอ
ทุกวันอือคือตอนเด็กๆน่ะเจอกันเรียนกัน
แต่โตเเนี่ยไม่ได้ไม่ได้เจอกันทุกวันแล้ว
ก็ไม่ได้คุยกันทุกวัน
อ่ะเรียกว่าบางที 1 ปี 1 ปีคุยกัน 1
ครั้งเพราะเพื่อนก็แต่งงานมีลูกครูเอ๋ก็
แต่งงานทุกคนมีงานแต่ว่าเมื่อไหร่ที่ครู
เอ๋มีเรื่องเรื่ใหญ่
ๆเรื่องใหญ่ๆอย่างเช่นคุณพ่อครูเอ๋เสีย
ชีวิตอ่าหรือคุณป้าครูเอ๋เสียชีวิตเพื่อน
สนิทมาคนแรกเลยอืใช่จะมาคนแรกเลยนะคะหรือ
ครูเอ๋แต่งงานครูเอ๋ก็ตกใจมากเพราะไม่ได้
เจอเพื่อนประมาณโอจริงๆต้องตั้งแต่คุณพ่อ
เสียชีวิตก็คือไม่ได้เจอเพื่อนประมาณ 4
ปี 5 ปีได้มั้งนะไม่ได้คุยกันเลยแล้ว
พอคุณพ่อเสียชีวิตเป็นจังหวะเพื่อนโทรมา
พอดีไอก็บอกเอ้อพ่อเสียชีวิตเพื่อนมาเลย
มาทั้งพี่ทั้งน้องแล้วก็มาช่วยแล้วก็ไม่
ใช่อยู่กรุงเทพฯใกล้ๆกันอยู่ไกลๆเพื่อนก็
มาแล้วก็ช่วยนะคะหรือตอนครูเอแต่งงาน
เพื่อนก็ไปแล้วก็ช่วยทำบ้านสวยๆนะคะอืน
เพื่อนสนิทก็จะเป็นแบบนี้หรือบางทีไม่
สบายไม่สบายแบบนิดหน่อยน่ะเพื่อนไม่มาไม่
สบายใหญ่ๆแบบเดินไม่ได้เพื่อนก็จะมานะคะ
ใช่เหมือนกันตอนเพื่อนสบายดีเอ๋ก็ไม่ไป
อ่าแต่ตอนเพื่อนมีปัญหาโอเคเอ๋ก็จะไปนะคะ
ตอนนี้ก็ที่บ้านเอ๋ก็เหลือคุณแม่คนเดียว
บ้านเพื่อนก็เหลือคุณแม่คนเดียวครูเอ๋ก็
อ่ะไปบ้านเอ๋บ้างไปบ้านเพื่อนบ้างนะก็ไป
หาคุณแม่เพื่อนแล้วก็คุยกันนะคะใช่ค่ะ
คล้ายๆกับเพื่อนของเรียมอ่ะถ้าเกิดไม่
สบายไม่สบายนิดหน่อยเพื่อนก็จะโทรมา
เพื่อนเรียมก็บอกว่า
เฮ้ยแบคทีเรียทำอะไรเธอได้ด้วยหรอก็จะแบบ
บางทีก็จะแบบเหมือนพูดพูดแบบไม่ดีอ่ะพูด
ไม่ดีใช่ปั้เออใช่แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดเราไม่
สบายมากๆอ่ะเค้าก็จะมาแบบเป็นยังไงบ้าง
อ่าอหรือหรือเป็นแบบนี้มั้ยที่ครูเรียม
บอกพูดไม่ดีสมมุติว่าครูเรียมกินอาหาร
น้อยแล้วก็ผอมอือเพื่อนสนิทก็จะบอกเฮ้ย
เรียมทำไม
ผอมผอมมากไปแล้วนะผอมเหมือนอะไรล่ะเหมือน
เหมือนอะไรดีเหนมาจิ้มฟันเหรอันมันมันตัว
เล็กด้วยนะเออพ่อพร้อมเหมือนเหมือน
ตะเกียบอเเรียกว่าตะพร้อมเหมือนตะเกียบ
เชี่ยวเออใช่หรือถ้าถ้าเป็นหรือบางทีถ้า
ถ้าอ้วนขึ้นอ้วนใชบางคนนะคะนักเรียนบางคน
เพื่อนสนิทก็อาจจะบอกว่า
โอ้ทำไมช่วงนี้อ้วน
จังโกรธมั้ยถ้าเพื่อนสนิทถามเรียมกินเยอะ
เหรออ้วนจังตอนนี้ถ้าเพื่อนสนิทพูดเลยมก็
แบบอยากกินอยากกินทำไม
ใช่ก็จะไม่รู้สึกเสียใจนะแต่ถ้าเกิดเป็น
คนอื่นๆพูดเราก็แบบไม่อยากฟังอืใช่ต้อง
เพื่อนสนิทใช่มั้ยคะต้องเพื่อนสนิทพูด
แล้วก็แบบทำไมหรออืทำไมแกอ้วนไปแล้วนะ
เดี๋ยวไม่สบายเนี่ยทำไมโเรื่องของฉันเย
อย่างงี้กล้าพูดแต่ถ้าเกิดครูเอ๋พูดแบบ
นี้เรียมไม่กล้าพูดนะว่าแบบเรื่องของฉัน
อะไรเงี้ยทำไมค่ะอ๋อครูเอ๋เป็นพี่ใช่มย
เออเป็นพี่ไม่สนิทนะไม่สนิทนะเราเราแค่ทำ
งานสนิทที่ทำงานแต่ไม่ใช่เพื่อนสนิทนะใช่
แต่ถ้าเป็นครูเอ๋มีคนถามอ่ะสมมติสมมุติ
ว่าเรียนเป็นเพื่อนสนิทครูเอ๋แล้วเรียม
ถามเหมือนกันอุ๊ยช่วงนี้อ้วนขึ้นน่ะอ้วน
เกินไปแล้วนะ
อือกินมยมีอีกไอศครีมอร่อยอ้วนแล้วเนี่ย
เธอเธออ้วนไม่เป็นไรอ้วนพรุ่งนี้ค่อยไป
วิ่งวันนี้กินก่อนเอาป่ะไม่เอาจริงอ่ะไม่
เอาไม่เอาไม่เอาเลิกกินเลิกกินพอไม่ต้อง
กินอร่อยมากนะอากาศร้อนๆอร่อยนะไม่ๆฉัน
ไม่อยากอ้วนกับเธอไม่อยากอ้วนหรอโอเคงั้น
เอาาอัน
นี้เอ๋จะชวนเพื่อนมากินด้วยกันค่ะ
[เพลง]
อือใชแต่ส่วนใหญ่เพื่อนเอกก็จะกิน
ออก็บอกไปด้วยกันได้ไปด้วยกันได้ไปด้วย
กันได้คือเอ๋จะรู้ว่าเพื่อนชอบอะไรเอเวลา
ใช่มถ้าเพื่อนบอกว่าอ้วนเอ๋ก็จะเดินไป
ซื้อไอติมอันเนี้ยของเอ๋อันเนี้ยไอติมของ
เพื่อนใช่หรือว่าแบบเวลาที่เราแบบเสียใจ
อ่ะูเออ๋อืเราก็แบบโทรศัพท์หาเพื่อนก็ได้
นะแบบตอนนี้แบบเสียใจมากเป็นอะไรแล้วก็
ร้องไห้กับเพื่อนสนิทได้อกหักโอเยอกหัก
จากอะไรอกหักต้องถามก่อนนะเดี๋ยวต้องถาม
ก่อนนะจากนักร้องในทีวีจากดู
ซีรีส์จากแฟนจริงๆต้องหนาเพื่อจะอกหักจาก
อะไรอือกหักแฟนอกหักจากแฟนตอนนี้แบบไม่
โอเคมาอยู่บ้านเป็นเพื่อนหน่อยอ๋อโอเค
โอเคเดี๋ยวไปหาอืมเป็นแบบนั้นแหละค่ะก็
เลยคิดว่าคงไม่มีใครที่จะอยู่กับเราได้ใน
ตอนที่แบบร้องไห้อยู่อ่ะอืไม่ใช่ทุกคนคิด
ว่าแบบนั้นค่ะออแต่จริงๆค่ะบางทีบางคนเรา
คิดว่าเป็นเพื่อนสนิทบางทีนะบางทีคิดว่า
เป็นเพื่อนสนิทแต่เวลาที่เราเสียใจ
ก็ไม่ไม่ไม่ฟังไม่ไม่อยู่กับเรานะฮะไม่
อยู่กับเราแล้วก็บางทีทำให้เราเสียใจมาก
ขึ้นอืคือคือไม่ไม่เข้าใจอ่ะอ่ามันเหมือน
กับว่าเวลาเรามีปัญหาจริงๆอ่ะไม่ไม่เคย
ช่วยอ่าอไม่ไม่เคยอะไรอย่าเงี้ยแต่แต่แต่
จริงๆบางทีก็รู้สึกเหมือนเพื่อนสนิทแต่
เวลามีปัญหาจริงๆทำให้เรามีปัญหาเพิ่ม
ขึ้นก็มีอ๋อเพื่อนสนิทที่ครูเอ๋กพูดถึงอน
เวลาปกติไม่เคยเคยเจอกันไม่เคยพูดไม่
สวัสดีเธอสวยขึ้นนะอันนี้ลิปสติกอะไรเี่
ไม่เคยแต่ว่าเวลามีปัญหาใหญ่ๆจะเจอกันทัน
ทีใช่ๆจะช่วยกันทันทีครูเอกก็เลยออจริงๆ
แล้วอันเนี้ยคือเรียกว่าเพื่อนสนิทหรือ
เพื่อนแท้น่าจะเป็นเพื่อนแท้นะน่าจะเป็น
มากกว่าเพื่อนสนิทเป็นเพื่อนแท้แต่ถ้า
เพื่อนสนิทธรรมดาก็อาจจะกินข้าว
ไปไหนด้วยกันเข้าใจกันแต่ว่าเวลามีปัญหา
ใหญ่ๆก็ไม่ได้อยู่ด้วยกันอืใช่อันนั้นแบบ
นจะได้ช่วยไม่เข้าใจอันนี้ครูเอกก็เลยคิด
อืสนิทกับเพื่อนแท้เนี่ยก็อาจจะต่างกัน
ด้วยเนาะใช่น่าจะแบบมีเพื่อนเพื่อนสนิท
แล้วก็แบบเพื่อนแท้ปีขั้นนึงใช่คือเอกก็
ไม่ไม่รู้ว่าเพื่อนสนิทครูเรียมเนี่ยเป็น
เหมือนกับเป็นเพื่อนแท้เลยเห็นมั้ยถ้าถ้า
เพื่อนที่แบบเราเสียใจแล้วเอยู่กับเรา
อันเนี้ยใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็สนุกก็อยู่กับเรา
เสียใจก็อยู่กับเราอย่างเงี้ยก็น่าจะเป็น
เพื่อนแท้ใช่ค่ะเขาแบบเคยแบบเรียมไปขับรถ
ไปจอดไว้ไกลๆแล้วก็แบบคเค้าก็ไปแบบไปส่ง
ไปส่งเรียมเพื่อเอารถอ่ะแบบมันไกลมากเลย
เรียมก็เลยแบบอุยขอบคุณมากขอบคุณมากแล้วเ
ต้องขับมาใซกลับร้อนๆน่ะ
อ๋อน่าสงสารใช่แล้วก็แบบรถครูเรียนเป็นรถ
อะไรรถปิกอัพป่ะไม่ๆๆค่ะตอนนั้นเรียมขับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปเหมือนกันไปจอดไว้อีกที่นึง
อ๋อโอเคนึกว่าถเป็นเอารถมอเตอร์ไซค์ใส่
ปิกอัพไม่แล้วก็แบบเคยมีเหตุการณ์ที่
เพื่อนเลียมเครียดมากเครียดมากแล้วเขาก็
คุยกับเรียมแล้วเขาบอกแบบเหมือนแบบอยาก
ฆ่าตัวตายอ่ะออวันนั้นเรียมก็เลยแบบไปนอน
นอนที่บ้านเขาเลยแบบไม่พูดอะไรนะไม่คุย
อะไรกันียมก็แบบโอเคเดี๋ยวนอนด้วยตรงนี้
แหละออใช่บางทีถ้าเกิดเพื่อนเสียใจมากๆ
ไม่ต้องพูดใช่ไม่ต้องพูดคำว่าสู้นะไม่
อยากฟังใช่แค่แบบอยู่ข้างๆจะเสียใจทำไม
ใช่มั้ยคะคือเวลาคนเสียใจเนี่ยเขาคบอก
ห้ามพูดคำว่าสู้ๆเลยนะอือ่าไม่รู้จะสู้
กับใครสู้กับตัวเองก็ไม่ไหวแล้วใช่สู้ก็
อ้าอันเนี้ยสู้นะอันนี้เหมือนกำมือต่อย
อ่ะเออก็แบบสู้ไม่สู้ไม่สู้ยอมแพ้นะยอมพ
ใช่ก็แค่อยู่ข้างๆใช่แล้วก็รับ
ฟังใช่ๆนั่นแหละอูยนี่แหละค่ะคือเพื่อน
เพื่อนสนิทแล้วก็อย่างที่ครูเอ๋พูดไปก็
คือเพื่อนแท้ใช่คือจริงๆเรื่องนี้สำคัญนะ
คะนักเรียนเวลาที่เพื่อนเราเสียใจเรื่อง
การรับฟังน่ะเสียเสใจปั๊บเนี่ยถ้าการรับ
ฟังเนี่ยจะทำให้รู้เลยว่าคนเนี้ยเป็น
เพื่อนสนิทหรือเป็นเพื่อนเฉยๆเพราะว่าถ้า
บางทีน่ะคนเราก็คิดไม่ดีได้เวลาเสียใจเรา
ก็อยากจะพูดใช่มพูดออกไปพอพูดออกไปปั๊บ
เพื่อนสนิทน่ะเขาจะรับฟังเฉยๆจนเราสบายใจ
เขาถึงบอกว่าอะไรแต่ไม่ใช่พอเราพูดคำไม่
ดีไม่ดีโออันนี้ไม่ใช่เพื่อนสนิทแล้วอาจ
จะแบบฆ่าตัวตายไป
เลยคือเค้าไม่แสดงว่าเค้าไม่เข้าใจเราเค
มองว่าเราไม่ดีจริงๆนะคะอือเพราะจริงๆคน
เราก็มีดีมีไม่ดีใช่มั้อืไม่ต้องบอกว่า
ไม่ดีรู้แล้วใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะแต่ถ้าพูดเล่นๆ
อารมณ์ดีๆโอ๊ยแกไม่ดีนะเรียมออันเนี้ย
เวลาเวลาแข็งแรงดีเวลาใจสบายๆแล้วพูดน่ะ
ไม่เป็นไรใช่มั้ยคะใช่คือเพื่อนสนิทเรา
ต้องรู้ว่าตอนเนี้ยเพื่อนกำลังดีดีใจหรือ
เสียใจดูหน้าเข้าใจเลยใช่อืแล้วนักเรียน
ล่ะคะแบบมีเพื่อน
สนิทเยอะมั้ยแล้วก็ทำอะไรกับเพื่อนสนิท
บ้าง
อืไปพาย
เรือไปไปกินอาหาร
เอ่อถ่ายรูปไปบ้านอ่าไปถ่าย
รูปมีอะไรอีกหรือว่าแบบไปคุยกันอาจจะแบบ
ไม่ชอบอะไรที่เหมือนกันแต่ว่าคุยกันได้
ใช่นะนั่นแหละประมาณนั้นแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลา
หมดแล้วใช่มั้ยคะครูเอ๋ค่ะใช่ค่ะใช่ต้อง
เจอกันใหม่ในคลิปหน้าแล้วค่ะค่ะแล้วนัก
เรียนบอกเรานะคะว่าทำอะไรกับเพื่อนสนิท
บ้างใช่นั่นแหละคอมเมนต์มานะคะค่ะโอเคลา
ไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋ลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย